DR. JAMES GRIME: Have you ever
heard of the time when they
tried to redefine pi,
to redefine pi
so that it was 3.2?
BRADY HARAN: I'm about to.
DR. JAMES GRIME: Yes, you are.
This is absolutely insane.
It's a true story, as well.
And it's absolutely crazy.
So this happened--
well, I don't think
that long ago.
It was 1897.
And there was a guy called Edwin
Goodwin, this amateur
mathematician who thought he had
solved one of the unsolved
problems of mathematics, a
problem that goes way back to
ancient Greece.
It was called squaring
the circle.
The problem is can you find a
square that has the same area
as a circle.
So this problem goes
way, way back.
And it's a favorite problem for
amateur mathematicians.
And this guy thought he had
solved the problem.
But implicitly in his proof,
he had assumed that pi was
exactly 3.2.
Now, he was so pleased with
his proof, he wanted to
copyright the proof itself so
that anyone using the proof
from that point on would have
to pay him royalties.
But he decided that the great
state of Indiana--
which is where he was from--
that the educational
establishments of Indiana
could use it for free.
How kind of him.
And so what he did was he
had a bill made up.
And he tried to pass it into law
that would recognize the
mathematical truth that
he had discovered.
But it would allow Indiana
to use it for free.
Though I think he had a friend,
someone he knew, who
was part of the House of
Representatives in Indiana.
And he made up this bill
saying that the great
mathematical truth of
squaring the circle.
Now, this bill went through
committees.
It went through the Education
Committee in the House of
Representatives.
And they obviously didn't know
what they were doing, because
they passed the bill.
And the representatives
actually passed it
unanimously, 67 to 0.
They passed it.
Now, this is the weird bit.
On the same day that they were
passing the bill, there was a
mathematician in the building.
He was there for a completely
different reason.
He was a guy called
Professor Waldo.
But he decided to sit in on
what they were discussing,
because it was about math.
So he was interested.
And he couldn't believe
what he was hearing.
They invited him to meet
Edwin Goodwin.
Oh, do you want to meet Edwin?
We're very proud of him.
He said, no, I meet enough crazy
people as it is, thank
you very much.
So this mathematical professor
then decided
to coach the Senate.
The next thing that happens is
the bill goes from the House
of Representatives
to the Senate.
So this professor coached the
senators so that they knew
what they were doing.
By this time, the newspapers
had heard of it.
They were mocking what
was going on.
So when it reached the Senate,
they threw it out.
They threw it out not before
having a bit of fun with it.
They had about half an hour
of maths puns and
making jokes about it.
Then they threw it out.
But seriously, there
are solutions--
"solutions"--
to squaring the circle, where
you take really good
approximations to pi.
More serious mathematicians--
for example, Ramanujan, who was
an Indian mathematician,
and a brilliant one at that--
he had a solution
to this as well.
So Ramanujan came up with an
approximation which meant that
if you made a circle with an
area of 140,000 square miles,
then you could have a square
with the same area.
And the sides of the square
would be off just by an inch.
So Edwin Goodwin had
done this in 1897.
And you can see the documents.
It's absolutely true,
this story.
You can look at the documents
yourself.
You can read it.
And it's a strange thing
to happen, as well.
Because the problem he was
trying to solve, squaring the
circle, was proved to
be impossible 15
years earlier, in 1882.
So I think we should have a
video about squaring the
circle and what it means.
BRADY HARAN: Shall we do that?
DR. JAMES GRIME: Shall
we do that?
BRADY HARAN: We'll film that.
We're about to film it now.
Tune in soon.
And we'll show you about
squaring the circle.
DR. JAMES GRIME: Let's have a
look at what you can do with
rules and compasses.
You can add numbers.
Look.
Here's a line.
And it has length a.
Then I add another
line of length b.
And the whole thing
is a plus b.